hello everyone and as many of you have
mentioned in my previous video
excellently is indeed a word here I took
this from dictionary calm excellently is
indeed a word so it's super excellently
and uh Nexen T and I can tell you how
excited I am to be able to use the word
an excellently in images video someday
hopefully soon
now before we check out this game it's a
game from round three of the very strong
international tournament in moss from
1936 best of luck to everyone in this
photo challenge it's a as usual it's a
two-fold question first can you find
Xhosa row kappa blanka that will bring
one point and four additional points any
player you recognize in this photo will
also bring you one point and this photo
is from 1928 so the quality of this
photo is amazing for 1928 so definitely
we should Marvel Edit for for a bit so
that being said 1936 the the third
international tournament in Moscow
Jose wrote capablanca with the white
pieces faces Nikolay Nikolayevich
aluminum now Nikolai Nikolai sure human
was one of the strongest masters in the
USSR in the 1930s he was three times
champion of Moscow and in the second
Moscow international tournament that
held that was held in 1935 he actually
defeated josé raúl capablanca in the
first round of that tournament which
most likely cost a couple monk a first
place in the end as first place was won
by Mika what Tony who was tied with
Salomon floor with 13 points and a cup
of Blanca finished with 12 points so
perhaps even causing him the tournament
last year so this year he has an
opportunity to to have his his revenge
now the first two games in this
tournament Capablanca started with the
raw first game okay that was kind that
was a draw against Elia Khan and second
game against Solomon floor I will also
put a link to that game in the
description below if you want to check
it out second game against the Solomon
floor
kappa blanka was down the exchange but
floor was unable to win that game but at
some point floor did have a win which
Capablanca demonstrated after the game
so not the greatest start to the
tournament and
is around three and Capablanca has a
chance to take his revenge for his loss
last year so let's check it out a couple
on has the white pieces like we said and
he opens with d4 now we have Knight to
f6 c4 b6 we have
Knight to c3 and now Knight B to d7
those 40 Mears key variation I would
have a four and now a five as 97 prepare
d5 a couple Blanca sees is more space
with d5 we have knife to c5 and now f3
as d4 pawn was attacked and here Bishop
to e7 as the night is already occupying
you know it's a nice square c5 b 4 is
definitely an idea here for white you
don't want to allow black to keep this
nice square if it like doesn't if you
don't have to and here a 5 would maybe
be a more principled modern move but
okay Bishop to e7
we have Bishop to e3 by capablanca now
comes castles and here kappa blanka
display before as a human didn't stop it
we have 937 and Bishop to d3 now
knighted to e8 and here comes Knight to
f3 okay so this is pretty much still
still do the opening couple Anka is
controlling much more spaces pawns on
the Queen side are nicely developed a 4
is coming all the pieces are developed
he's ready to castle and everyone still
has to figure out what to do with his
knights and how he will develop the
bishops and it's very interesting as
this is a tournament from 1936 we
actually do have a photo of the two of
them playing this game perhaps even
close to this position so here it is the
origin of the photo is unknown so it is
unknown who took the photo I took it
from Douglas Griffin and his twitter
account as he does post a lot of a lot
of historic just for us I will also put
a link to his profile in the description
below so you can check it out if you
want to enjoy some more all chest photos
so there we have a couple Blancas with
the white pieces on the right they're a
huge ashtray apparently on the board you
know a lot of people in the crowd and a
huge chest clock and there is a room in
on the left and you can see that the the
sheet for the for the moves appears to
be huge for some
reason but okay yeah definitely
interesting is sometimes you know you
can't even find a photo of the players
that play the game in the year 2000 and
here's a beautiful photo of the two of
them from 1936 so let's continue with
the game
we have g6 as you do have to do
something about that night on e8 couple
Blanca castles we have a five now trying
to break White's nice pawn chain a three
we have nine to g7 and now Bishop to h6
not allowing this night to go anywhere
and for a moment preventing black from
pushing f5 we have f6 Queen to b3 and
now come skin to h8 you don't want a
keeper King on this diagonal as it could
be very annoying in the future so rook
the c1 now we have a captures a captures
and now c5 Knight to a4 putting pressure
on the c5 pawn so C captures on b4 we
have Queen captor some before and now f5
here
Newman gets a very nice idea that well
that will that will prove to be correct
he captures on f5 we have G captures on
f5 okay now your pawns in front of the
King are a bit ruined but you do have a
very strong Center Knight to g3
pressuring the f5 pawn and now comes
Bishop to g5 this was his idea
forcing the trade of the dark square
bishop and after captures captures you
take advantage of the fact that white
cannot capture on d6 because the knight
is hanging but also black has a second
threat that is Queen to III check
picking up the undefended the bishop on
d3 so capablanca plays a ropes e2 e1 not
allowing Queen to e3 check we have Queen
to h4 and now look to f2 rope to f2 a
very nice idea now if f4 is pushed then
night and come to f1 2 D 2 all the way
to e4 and also now Queen d4 will not
come with check so and also it creates a
very nice square for the bishop on f1 so
Queen to d4 now pinning this rook
attacking the bishop and the bishop does
come to F 1 we have rook to f6 with the
idea of transferring group to h6 and
creating a King side attack
Knight to c3 and now comes a rope to h6
so now Queen - Queen to h4 could be an
idea but also a lot of other moves could
could become possible something like
rock captures on h2 Queen coming to h4
with check a lot of things are possible
so here a couple Blanca played Knight G
2 e 2 and this is a very exciting moment
in the game here black should simply
move his queen for example Queen to a7
seems to be alright but this is the
critical moment of the game and here
Nicholai Nicholai which women played
tonight the c5 and it's very interesting
so feel free to pause the video here but
not for too long and figure out why this
he play Knight to c5 allowing Knight
captures Queen on d4 I'm just kidding
don't do it as nice the c5 was actually
a terrible blunder by room and here he
completely blundered the Queen so here a
couple mangas simply played Knight
captures on d4 and Nikolay Nikolayevich
illumine who was considered to be one of
the strongest strongest Soviet masters
resigned the game so yeah a lot of a lot
of you know preparation went into this
game and the Capablanca really wanted to
win it as he did lose to rumen in the
previous mosque of tournament but here
actually the simple night ge2 won him
the game after 95 Knight captures Queen
and the game was finished so yeah this
is actually the first win kappa blanka
achieved in this tournament this is
round 3 and we're also gonna cover a
couple of more games from couple blanca
in this tournament and also a couple a
couple of more games from both make in
this tournament as they were going
really going head to head until the end
of the tournament and until you finish
voting for my next big series i am
definitely gonna create a mini series of
this tournament and if you still haven't
voted for my next series there will be a
link in the description description
below the first thing you will see i
will be a link where you will be able to
vote so that's that's the game couple
lanka vs. women from 1936 international
tournament in moscow i do hope you
enjoyed it room indefinitely didn't and
it wasn't like i mean ok he might have
been in time pressure but as i've read
he had eight more minutes for for the
next 14 moves so I mean that's eight
minutes is no
excuse to play a move like 95 but yeah
and as this channel is nearing its
200,000 subscribers milestone I will
probably do some sort of a celebratory
stream as it would be alright to
commemorate such such an event probably
on Friday but regardless of when this
milestone will be reached I will also do
subscribers tournaments tomorrow just
you know as I haven't streamed in quite
a while to get you know to
get ready for it so hopefully you will
all be able to make it I will you know
keep you posted probably in tomorrow's
video so yeah that's basically it we're
gonna check a couple of more games from
this tournament I would like to thank
personal Elizabeth Schwartz for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon most likely with another game
from this wonderful tournament that is
the 1936 international tournament in
Moscow thank you all and I'll see you
soon